good morning John there's something
special about humans and this is
objectively true some people will think
that their sports team is particularly
special because they know the whole
history of that team and all of the
intricate details of players on it they
don't know all those details for other
teams so they see their team as the best
most interesting most unique thing
that's cognitive bias and it's fine
sports well sport Steve they're equally
special meaning none of them are but
that is not true of humans as a species
among the immense variety of life on
Earth there are lots of organisms that
are good at particular things like
giraffes are super tall and cheetahs and
antelope are super fast and some
managing eukaryotes are particularly
good at surviving and thriving in
boiling water but humans aren't like
particularly good at certain things one
or two or good at all the things you can
dive into the crushing depths of the
bottom of the ocean and travel faster
than any other animal we can even escape
the safe little bubble of our atmosphere
and not dyes uniqueness about humans is
obvious even if it weren't true I think
we would think it does let a lot of
people to think different things about
what the thing is that makes us so
exceptional there's like opposable
thumbs the people have thought maybe
which is ridiculous because raccoons and
for a while we thought that the thing
that set us apart was tool use which no
because like Ravens and primates and
dolphins it's not that then maybe it's
self-awareness maybe it's knowing that I
am a thing who is me and that allows me
to think differently about the world but
also seems like a lot of animals are
also self-aware that's not it well I've
decided and I don't know what gives me
the right to do this but I have decided
that the thing that sets us apart as
people that makes us capable of air
conditioning in hot showers and lunar
landings in nuclear war can be summed up
in one word and that word is stories
this sounds a little froofy to you let
me remind you that there was a time
before email the four phones before in
newspapers before the written word even
when Humanity was first benefiting from
the massive utility of passing
tremendous amounts of information from
generation to generation the vehicle for
the passing of that information was the
story stories were and I think that they
still are how we define ourselves and
our culture and even our technology in
science every human society that wants
to behave differently first has to
change the stories that they tell
stories in songs in books on the stage
on podcasts our
round the campfire help us define who we
are we are made of stories so when I
realized that we had a full-time staff
that was working on VidCon but they had
certain lull periods in their year
because VidCon only happens once he
hears people were excited about creating
another conference in a different place
in a different time of the year
celebrating a different thing I had to
think what is a cultural institution
that is as important to me or more
important to me than the institution of
online video which is obviously very
important to me so I went with stories
which is admittedly broad so this year
2015 on October 9th and 10th in
Minneapolis Minnesota at the Minneapolis
Convention Center we will be celebrating
stories at a new event called nerdcon
stories and yes we're leaving the door
opened for maybe future nerdcon other
things we'll have panels and talks and
performances and question-and-answer
sessions in a tiny little vendor room
and yes this is going to be much smaller
of an affair than VidCon is but our
special guests at least in my book are
certainly not a step down Hank and John
Green will be there so there's that well
have fantasy authors like Pat Rothfuss
Sandra Claire and Holly black and Mary
Robinette Kowal sci-fi authors like John
Scalzi and Paulo becae gallupi young
adult authors like Jacqueline Woodson
and Stephanie Perkins a lots of things
that aren't booked like musicians like
Kimya Dawson and decid darling shows
like welcome to night Vale and wits and
story Collider organizations that
promote stories and game developers and
poets and playwrights this is just the
beginning of our list we have a lot of
time to continue planning and adding new
people to our event we're very excited
about nerdcon stories I think it's going
to be an exceptional event basically a
little bit designing it just so I will
enjoy let's be honest two people who are
able to come we expect this event to
sell out pretty quickly because it's not
very big
so nerdcon calm to get tickets for
people who can't stories are universal
and they are everywhere and I encourage
you to participate in this culture of
stories and just to revel in the general
wonderfulness and humanity of the
institution of stories John I'll see you
on Tuesday
Oh